so let's go to
my ghosting for this week which is
you're gonna see crazy you know we talk
about crazy from time to time
we got some crazy here for you fellas uh
okay so
let's remove this and i gotta share with
audio
chrome tab
boom
tab audio okay
oh
okay so
let's get some volume here and speed it
up so we don't have to take the whole
six minutes
and here we go guys this is a
there'll be a lesson in this one you
ready let's do this and if you can't
hear just let me know in the chat but i
believe it should be working you know
the time you said you would i have a
busy day today if i have to stay on
schedule yeah well that's because we
have a very organized producer because
uh the three of us are definitely not
that organized
so so let's talk about uh so we're not
interfering with your busy schedule
let's talk about uh this guy noah how
did you guys meet what's the deal
um
so we kind of met online at one of the
dating apps um but we've been going up a
bit and that now he won't get back to me
and his name noah it's been seven days
today being the eighth and at this point
i have to assume that he's trying to go
to me and i just want to know why
okay okay
i mean yeah a week that's definitely a
ghost thing um did you guys get a fight
or anything like was there anything that
went wrong weird vibes yeah
no like we just got back from a trip to
new york city which was the uh okay so
that was the day since we got back from
new york city um he has stopped
responding to me okay so something
clearly happened in new york
maybe he didn't
tell me he was supposed to call me 8 30
in the morning the following day to
reflect on the trip and then that call
never came i love a good recap call no
it's a reflection so
you notice she's saying he was supposed
to call me at 8 30 in the morning to
reflect on that trip and the call never
came
she also mentioned if you guys caught at
the start but she's like oh i'm so glad
you guys called me at the schedule time
because i have a busy day today listen
to this dude when he feeds back okay so
so here's what we're gonna do
we're going to call noah next and have
you listening on the phone do you think
he can stay quiet for us
yes awesome
and people wonder why you just want to
get married and if you're not familiar
with ghosted it's when people have other
people disappear on them and then they
call us and then we have to make the
call to see why and amelia that's you
with this guy no and the crazy thing is
you guys just back got back from new
york on a trip and he hasn't called you
since
exactly okay now it's been how many days
this is day number eight day number
eight okay he missed an appointment he
had a pointed call what was the what
were you guys going to talk about
but we were going to talk about our trip
to new york we had such a good time we
did like everything that i had on the
itinerary everything was going great and
now i haven't heard from them everything
that she had on the itinerary just
pointing that out just just pay
attention here
okay all right and there's no fights no
disagreements no awkwardness no no no no
we had a good time because all signs
point to something happening on that
direction yeah it does say okay all
right so um all right well why don't we
just do this we're gonna call him you're
gonna be laying on the phone you gotta
be silent but here's the thing sometimes
the answers can be pretty damn harsh are
you sure you wanna hear what he has to
say
yes
okay
you think
yeah
all right so let's give noah a call
hello
hi there looking for noah
uh this is him who is this no it's adam
wild tj and jax from 99 good virgin
radio good morning hi
oh hey what's up virgin radio how's it
going man things good
yeah pretty good how are you good how
was new york
well
it was it was good
okay
just
you know just just wondering why why why
you haven't reached out to amelia since
you guys went to new york
together you can see how that would be
weird that you would go on a trip with
somebody and then never talk to them
again
oh yeah uh
you know
i i realized something about amelia and
i think i saw it coming
but wasn't super sure
do you want to tell us what that was a
discovery
yeah
she's a control freak right like my life
was basically turning into one big
schedule and you know i just couldn't
handle it uh it was kind of cute when we
first started dating she would you know
plan everything out and write it all
down which you know it made things
refreshing because i didn't have to
worry about coming up with stuff but you
know she carries around this little grid
with a pen and crosses off every
activity we do once we're done and you
know while it was like cute and
endearing at first it kind of started to
get old and when we came back from new
york
man like if one thing was out of
schedule while we were there even by
minutes she was not happy bossy can you
give us an example
uh well we were having dinner and uh she
just
went off on a waiter for taking just a
few extra minutes to bring our food she
was super nervous we're gonna be late
for this broadway show that we had
plenty of time for or like when i
suggested you know
adding an extra 15 minutes for sleep
then what she had penciled in she just
absolutely lost her [ __ ] which told me
you know pretty early on if we were all
scheduled at any point this trip would
be a nightmare so you know i just sucked
it up until i got home it doesn't sound
like fun am i the only one who loves an
itinerary like that i dated a girl that
was very very type a and it was it was
awesome i love it down to like sleep
schedule yep listen i think it's i think
it's only fair probably what to do no i
just want to say tell me what to do okay
i love it likes to be bossed around yeah
yeah um i think it's only two
guys
yeah okay so
uh no amelia has been listening the
entire time she's on the line
oh great
sorry amelia what's your rebuttal to
this one
uh good morning noah nice to know that
you still exist so you're upset that i'm
organized
hi emilia
i'm sorry but the whole world cannot
revolve around your stupid grid right
like you scheduling our breakup call was
when i had to end it so when we got back
i told her hey i'll call you when i get
home and then she pulls out her schedule
like i don't have that in the schedule
you can call tomorrow at 8 30 in the
morning no and that's when i was just
like not done
well i did not see this coming uh
are you ready what are you writing yeah
what are you putting no she's writing a
new grid that's exactly what she's doing
which is something i would like to take
and shred the pieces everybody has their
thing everybody has their things so i
mean
my grade in my life no longer reference
you know the virgin the time i allotted
for this call it's gone past five
minutes so i have to go now okay
all right okay well thank you thank you
the time that i allotted for this call
is done now so i have to go she says
captain organized
holy smokes
you ever dated a chick like that
you like
why would you even take a trip with her
i guess he
i guess he didn't have anything else
better going on so he was like yeah
let's do this trip hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you